Okay Charles what do you think?
>> About what?
>> Let's just go through these.
The ones that don't have names yet
and give them names.
Kind of think through what it is
that they are like and label them.
>> Okay sure we can do that all right.
If the first one is a regular MDP and
and
what makes it a regular MDP is
that you're doing an expectation.
Over the next best action
that will be taken, right?
>> Right,
the best next action I would say.
>> Right that's the right
way of saying it.
So, here the only difference
between the second one and
the first one is that instead of doing
an expectation you're going to only pay
attention to the worst possible
state you could get into.
>> Mm, okay.
So we're taking out the actual
stochastic dynamics of the MDP and
replacing it with something
that is minimizing.
>> Right and
so that means if we were thinking
about the function at the very top,
the Q star, is not kind of the value
of taking an action in a particular
state given that you are then going to
do the best thing from that point on.
But it's sort of the value you would get
is you always assumed
the worst thing could happen.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And if that were true everywhere,
then you would be valuing things
by the worst possible outcome.
So that would be a kind of, I don't know
what the right word is, maybe something
like a pessimistic MDP, or
a risk-averse MDP, something like that.
>> Good.
Worst case MDP, maybe.
>> Mm-hm yeah.
>> It's also related to,
in control theory,
the notion of H infinity control.
That H infinity control basically says,
I don't know what's going to happen so
let me assume that the worst
thing's going to happen.
>> Okay so pessimistic sort
of describes the outlook
on the world of this equation but
is risk averse the right thing?
This suggests that I will end up trying
to choose actions that put me places
where the least bad thing could happen.
>> Well, I mean,
I wouldn't quite think of it that way.
So, it's almost as if
the environment is out to get you.
So, instead of just randomly
transitioning you to some state
it's always putting you in a state
that makes you the least happy of all
the states that you could go to.
>> Oh, so grad school.
>> [LAUGH] Well,
it depends where you go to grad school.
Like, Rhode Island's
a pretty good state.
All right, so we're going to be
placed in a state that is worse for
us, and once we get there,
then we get to choose an action.
We get to choose the action
that's best for us.
So it's also almost a kind of game,
where we get to make a move, and
then the environment makes a move,
and then we make a move, and
then the environment makes a move.
>> Okay, I like that, I like that.
But that means you would want to
choose the action that would get you
to the place where kind of
the least worst thing can happen.
>> Yeah, that's right.
Right, so us, the agent,
the ones who's doing the deciding,
is trying to be risk averse relative
to what the environment might do to it.
>> Right, sure that makes perfect sense.
So risk averse is not a bad description.
>> Good.
So other answers I would accept here
include things like adversarial dynamics
or two player game, things like that.
I guess you could also,
notice the way this is written here.
This is the min over all next states so
this is really going to always
transition us to the worst state.
Not the worst state that makes any
sense, because we didn't do something
like for all states in the set
of states that are reachable
with probability greater than zero, but
that's a little bit more constrained.
We didn't constrain it, so
really it could just be MDP that makes
you sit in the worst possible place, and
just pummels you over and over again.
But I don't think there's
a nice succinct name for that.
>> I thought that was pretty succinct,
what you said.
>> All right, good.